das ist wirklich eine absolute sensation
es gibt sauberes wasser auf dem mars
das ist was ergibt das war ja schon
lange klar in welchen mengen und ob es
nutzbar sein würde
das war alles andere als gewiss jetzt
gibt es aber neue kenntnisse und die
sind wirklich sensationell
der mars reconnaissance orbiter hat
sogar massive vorkommen entdeckt wie
genau und vor allem die frage aller
fragen wie ist die lage auf dem mars und
was bedeutet das für zukünftige
mars-mission jetzt den klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
erst einmal vielen dank an uwe schmidt
der uns heute morgen den link per mail
geschickt hat ja das sind meldungen die
das herz höher schlagen lassen
der mars reconnaissance orbiter hat
tatsächlich massive eisschichten unter
dem marsboden entdeckte wasser das ist
ja schon länger durch zahlreiche
beweisen belegt gibt es in form von eis
auf dem roten planeten 2008 gab es die
ersten fotos als der nasa phoenix maß
länder am 15 juni dem 21 tag seiner
mission mit seiner schaufel eisfrei
legte eine absolute sensation zum ersten
mal war damit klar und sichtbar es gibt
wasser auf dem mars in eis vom war ein
absoluter gänsehautmoment zahlreiche
weitere erkenntnisse wurden inzwischen
gewonnen aber zum beispiel die
entdeckung von flüssigem wasser wurde im
nachhinein in frage gestellt im video
kein leben auf dem mars möglich hatten
wir darüber berichtet aber bis heute
blieben zahlreiche fragen offen wie viel
wasser gibt es ist es sauber genug kann
es genutzt werden denn das ist eine der
absolut wichtigen fragen kann eine
zukünftige mars-mission das eis auf dem
mars nutzen um wasser daraus zu gewinnen
mit der aktuellen entdeckung ist die
nasa der beantwortung dieser fragen
nähergekommen
der mars reconnaissance orbiter fand das
eis an steilhängen die durchmaß winde
freigelegt worden waren und so kein
staub die schichten bedeckte dadurch
konnte er mit seiner high rise kamera
der high resolution imaging science
experiment kamera aufnahmen machen die
beeindruckendes zeigen zum einen scheint
das eis sehr klar zu sein man könnte
wahrscheinlich eben rein ins wasser
daraus gewinnen dann ist die schicht mit
knapp 130 metern sehr dick und diese
schichten die können jetzt die
klimageschichte des mars sehr gut
nachvollziehbar machen so kann mit einer
mission zu diesen stellen in zukunft
auch erkundet werden ob das leben auf
dem mars gab oder hätte geben können
oder sogar noch gibt zitat unter etwa
einem drittel der marsoberfläche
befindet sich oberflächennahes eis das
die jüngste geschichte des mars
aufgezeichnet hat so der hauptautor der
studie können dann das vom astrobiologie
science center des us geological survey
und eines ist jetzt für die von der
europäischen weltraumagentur esa
geplanten exomars mission eine wirklich
unglaubliche erkenntnis jetzt ist zum
ersten mal bekannt in welcher tiefe sich
das eis befindet und das ist der
absolute wahnsinn
ein bis zwei meter und genau in diese
tiefe soll die exomars mission zum
ersten mal
sie wird damit ein wichtiger meilenstein
für eine bemannte mars-mission denn dann
kann wirklich geklärt werden ob aus
diesem eiswasser gewonnen werden kann
das ist wirklich ein riesiger schritt
für die raumfahrt da kriege ich echt
gänsehaut der absolute wahnsinn
unfasslich ich bin so gespannt was sich
jetzt noch alles aus dieser entdeckung
ergibt denn sie bedeutet ja auch das
eine mission auch komplett ohne bohrung
auskommt und an diesen hängen bis zu 130
meter in die tiefe in den marsboden
blicken kann
hammer wenn ihr keine nachricht vom mars
verpassen wollt dann wird mir ja kein
aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke der nur dann
verpasst er kein video hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken
außerirdisches leben auf dem mars neue
indizien ja ansonsten würde ich mal
sagen bis dann bleibt dran